make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are at the conclusion of
deceased and here's the thing deceased
is an amazing story it's ridiculous how
good it is and to be honest always even
sure was gonna be this great right I was
kind of on the fence but Tom Taylor does
what Tom Taylor always does which has
come out in spectacular fashion
right so in the last video we basically
ended with Superman being infected and
it was like okay so this is basically
the end of everybody right like nobody's
gonna make it out alive here because
you're talking about the Man of Steel
like the most powerful superhero on
earth after the Martian Manhunter and
the Martian Manhunter was already
destroyed that the crazy thing about
this is it's almost it's it's incredible
the way this is done because it kind of
parallels Superman as we know him as a
superhero in comparison to Superman in
terms of what's actually going on right
so it's like you know faster than a
speeding bullet more powerful than a
locomotive able to leap tall buildings
in a single bound the amazing man who's
gonna kill you all it's Superman but
it's crazy because the way this
narration is taught is like all hope was
lost at 11:48 a.m. and it's kind of nuts
because what we end up doing is jumping
over to the fortress of solitude right
which is where basically the last of the
superheroes are all essentially gathered
together it's cool to see Tom Taylor do
this because what they end up doing is
really Damian Wayne kind of pops up and
says Batman always had a kind of back-up
plan always has a plan to basically deal
with superheroes and it turns out it was
for pretty much everybody except uh
Green Arrow
Green Arrow's kind of disappointed
because he's like Batman didn't have a
plan for me he didn't really consider me
dangerous but it's like now Green Arrow
I'm sorry man now one of the things that
I want to kind of point out here is a
Damian Wayne it's not really a huge
thing but Damian Wayne never refers to
himself as Batman Damian Wayne always
says like well he always you first to
Batman is a wholly different person
right like Batman had plans like he's
just kind of a stand-in right there he's
not really Batman he's just temporarily
taking his place it's interesting there
because it shows that one Damian Wayne
is not accepted the fact that his
father's actually dead and two Damian
Wayne does not see himself as being
Batman in the same way that Bruce Wayne
was and so far as he's not really as
good of a Batman is Bruce was which it's
kind of a true statement but it's also a
true it's also a great little kind of
tribute to Bruce himself and so in
addition to that we also end up learning
that of course Damian Wayne has a piece
of Kryptonite on him because you know
how are you gonna defeat Superman and
then also diana is the one like Wonder
Woman's one who's been kind of sitting
down and saying we have to find like I
also have schemes
have ideas on how to take down these
various superheroes and so what she ends
up doing is taking this kryptonite and
merging it with essentially metal and
then crafting a sword out of it which is
a genius idea because when it comes to
Wonder Woman here's the important thing
to understand about Wonder Woman I
wouldn't go as far as to say the people
sleep on her that she's like unless
she's a she's a character they're worse
it's kind of like nobody really
appreciates how capable she is but
Wonder Woman fights to the end that's
the nature of her character she fights
threats head-on she doesn't really rest
on her laurels and kind of wait to see
how things unfold and so at the same
time the idea here is okay this is gonna
be the case then basically we take the
various guys and we fall back right like
we fall back as best we can so we're
gonna take one group they're all gonna
head to Gotham they're gonna grab as
many of those survivors as they possibly
can and they can only grab like a small
number of them right like a very very
small number of them comparatively
speaking
and then basically head out right so
they end up going to Gotham and they're
grabbed as many of the survivors as they
can and then they go to they go to end
up going to the mascara to try to grab
as many of the survivors as they
possibly can the problem is that once
this arc arrives at the mascara they
don't arrive alone and it's actually one
of the coolest things that go on here's
one the coolest things that happens
there's this tempest this massive storm
that takes place outside of the island
and when everybody's kind of gathering
around waiting to see what it is
ultimately it's the arrival of Aquaman
who summoned the Kraken and this is one
of the coolest things in the whole story
right because it's like Aquaman should
like Aquaman here's the thing about
Aquaman up until Dan Abnett wrote the
character as part of like DC rebirth I
never I was never really interested in
it I was gonna like Aquaman is a guy
who's there and he talks to fish and
Aquaman fans hate it when you say that
but it's true but like when you read Dan
Abbott's run on Aquaman it's like one of
the greatest Aquaman epics that I think
that I've ever read either in hindsight
or or having read more recently but like
seeing Aquaman show up here with like an
entire army of Atlanteans that in turn
is channeling the kraken is a sight to
behold but the first question that I had
here is how is he able to find the
mascara because the mascara is an island
that cannot be found except by those who
already know where it is but then like
Tom Taylor answers this in a like with a
quickness what he says is that under
normal circumstances no the mascara
cannot be found instead what ended up
happening here is that when famous Kira
was turned into an island its boundaries
were expanded in order to make way for
all these refugees it took it out of its
safe zone and it just brought it into
the main world right land to the main DC
Universe which technically was always
kind of the case there's this kind of
dimensional barrier that sort of
permeates and exists around them is here
that keeps people from finding it that
was removed when they
centrally turn it into a haven for
anybody to be able to access and so
because of that it was easily found by
Aquaman and all of his forces and they
just come rolling in here and tearing
everything up Green Arrow gets his due
which is kind of cool here because he
shoots an arrow through the eye or
through the head of Aquaman and he's
like you see I'm dangerous I shot an
arrow half a mile through like raging
winds and then hit a guy in the head but
basically it's calling in everybody they
can write so cassie sandsmark Wonder
Girl is already here you end up having
like all these Amazons that end up
charging directly into the fray against
the Atlanteans and then half a world
away
you've got Wonder Woman that you've got
the new Green Lantern Dino lance and
you've got cyborg who go charging in
against Superman and the cool thing
about this is this is like a colossal
fight in scale right I mean this is
really a fight to save the world it's
really what this says if Superman wins
the arcs will fall if the Amazons lose
the arc in Atlantis will fall there's
massive casualties on each side and the
struggling thing about this for the
Amazons right the biggest struggle about
this is you're talking about a
sisterhood these are women who have
fought together for for eons right who
have fought together as friends or live
together as friends for eons and eons
and eons right imagine that you had a
friend that you'd known for like a
thousand years and then imagine like
that you had to kill him right they they
turn against you and seemingly the blink
of an eye and that's what's going on
here is like these are our allies that
have fought together forever and then
suddenly they turn into enemies when
they're bitten and they're converted
into these you know undead anti-life
zombies and so it's kind of crazy
because what ends up happening here is
basically once all these refugees are
onto the ark and it's like we have to go
we've got to bail we can't stay here if
we do this Ark is gonna be destroyed and
so the order comes down from Hippolyta
the leader of the Amazons who says flee
get out of here leave us here like those
of us who are not on the ark leave us
here we'll fight we'll hold off as best
we can but essentially their sacrifice
to their life is a suicide mission
you're talking about with what amounts
to at this point maybe three four
possibly five Amazon's pulling off an
army of of Atlanteans it's not gonna
happen right and so ultimately we're
kind of left with the idea that like all
these different these different Amazons
basically end up falling and the ark
makes it to safety following that and
this is kind of a cool moment following
that you kind of switch back to Superman
and the end here's the thing about Dinah
Lance as the Green Lantern she's capable
but the issue with her as a Green
Lantern is she doesn't really have the
experience that the other Green
Lantern's do she's literally flying by
the seat of her pants so pretty like a
giant horn and then doing her her can
there
cry into the horn and then just like
blowing it into Superman that's cool but
in order to be an effective Green
Lantern what you need is finesse you
need the ability to understand how to
bob and weave how to dodge various
targets now at the same time you are
also talking about a super fast guy
who's astronomically strong so it's not
an easy feat it's not an easy thing but
the issue with this is a Superman almost
gets the upper hand on Black Canary and
almost kills her until his arm is cut
off by Wonder Woman the problem with
this is that while Wonder Woman does get
the upper hand on Superman for a moment
without hesitation he takes out Wonder
Woman and that's what made Superman so
dangerous as this this zombie monster
thing is because in doing that Superman
is he's not hesitating here like he
wants to kill the imperative drive that
he has to kill and destroy as much as he
possibly can and so there's there's it's
not like oh my god I'm getting ready to
kill Wunderland it's not like that it's
da BAM and then just like punches a hole
in her and that's basically the end of
that is it's a crazy thing to kind of
see because with Wonder Woman basically
out of the picture now immediately
Superman takes off and starts going
after the arch and this is when you get
to what's probably the greatest point in
the story right like the greatest moment
this story it's quick because basically
like the orcs have made it off of Earth
right they're out there by the moon
they're on there they're essentially on
their way out cut on Taylor is so
amazing at this this is what I want to
see I want to see DC's to continue which
you know well we'll talk about we'll
talk about that once we get to the end
but like they get outside of Earth
they're over there by the moon they're
basically taking off and you've got
Jonathan and you've got Damien standing
on one of the Ark's and Jonathan's like
my father's coming and Damien's like
yeah you're your dad's on his way it's
not some grandiose gesture it's nothing
like that it's just like tell my mom I
love her and look after her and then
like he basically tells Louis like I
know what I'm doing everything is gonna
be okay I promise I know what I'm doing
and then he just leave the ship and goes
to confront his dad the issue with this
is this like a moment right like like
Superman's charging towards you arched
by Jonathan Kent goes charging towards
Superman and in a moment is able to
basically knock him unconscious and
that's basically it that's all that we
get but this is why this moment is so
cool
and this is why this moment matters so
much is because this is Jonathan Kent
right this is what we would expect from
the son of Superman we would expect the
son of Superman to understand that
what's important here is the valuation
of life that this man is not his father
this man used to be his father but it's
not his father now and his task the last
thing his father assigned him was to
ensure the safety of everyone
that's the choice jonathan has to make
is racing in in fighting his dad which
is a crushing situation right like if he
killed Superman it be patricide but it's
a cool thing to see because it's like
this is what he has to do at the same
time like for the most part it's a
stopgap measure it's really what it what
it appears to be because at the end of
the day despite how capable Jonathan is
he's not on the same level as his father
and so once Superman comes to then
presumably the fight would continue but
Jonathan likely wouldn't be able to end
it but none of that matters because wild
wild Dinah Lance is sitting out do this
wise love Tom Taylor
well Dinah Lance is sitting out there
right she suddenly hears attention Green
Lantern of sector to 81 for the cavalry
has arrived
and the entire Green Lantern Corps comes
racing in with ganthet and the Guardians
of the Universe and it's like dude dude
is the coolest thing it's like one of
the greatest things ever because like
okay so like they're basically all safe
because there's no way Superman could
overcome every single one of these Green
Lantern's and that's really kind of how
it goes right plus they have ganthet who
would be more than enough to destroy
Superman just in his current form and so
what isn't happening is they're just
kind of standoff for a second why
Superman just kind of stands there just
sort of looks you know and tries to
figure out how it is that he can destroy
these guys and like you Anthon initially
holds off if Superman goes racing into
the Sun and it's like what in the hell
is he doing it was like he's feeding
he's absorbing the energy of the Sun and
basically that's when everything kind of
gets cut off and that's when they're
like we have to leave and the reason why
is because if Superman drains out all
that solar energy than one he's probably
gonna be God - you're powerful right
like Superman 1 million powerful but at
the same time is gonna kill all life on
Earth because while the earth while the
earth does have heat inside of it by a
virtue of like the ozone layer that heat
won't last forever is it's like having a
warm house and then cutting off your
heat eventually that eat is gonna
dissipate through the windows and
ultimately your house if you give it
long enough is gonna become as cold as
the outside or pretty close to it and so
as a result of that the earth is
basically doomed and that's basically
what they say is like the Green
Lantern's the guardians of the universe
our quarantine earth they're basically
cutting earth off and so like
everybody's essentially got to go like
there's there's there's no seam in the
planet anymore because there's no way to
sustain life on the planet anymore so
all those humans who were left behind
are all guaranteed to die there's no
rescuing them there's no getting them
out and so it kind of sucks here because
what you end up doing is jamming back to
earth itself and where cyborg has
managed to use the lasso of truth around
Wonder Woman this is actually genius by
Tom Taylor like he comes to this
realization
the lasso of truth compels you to speak
the truth right so we asked wonder what
do you have a voice can you speak and
she refers you something says yes we
have a voice right so what this
indicates is that these zombies these
anti-life monsters more or less have a
hive mind and so following that the
question becomes is there a cure is
there a way to end this virus because
it's basically what it is like you're
suddenly just a viral infection is there
a way to end it and the response is yes
there is a way to end it so when cyborg
asks like what's the way to cure this
the response is that the cure is in you
but you're the only way to cure this
thing you're the cause of all that's
right like your man in machine you are
the the way by which the vector by which
this was spread that it was a it was a
mathematical equation that spread from
your machine components into your human
element and then spread throughout the
rest of the world the problem with this
is that where cyber begins to panic and
realizes hey I need to tell somebody
what's going on I need to go tell the
people on the arch Wonderwoman grips his
head off so no one knows that there's a
cure for this thing no one knows that
there's a cure for this for this
infection and so ultimately what you end
up having is is the guardians of the
universe who guide the Earthlings back
to their new home which they dub of
earth to which is a cool little nod to
the earth to continuity and basically
the story ends but here's what I want to
know is like if Superman was absorbing
all that energy from the Sun what
happens to Superman right like what goes
on with that
that's why stories like this are cool is
because it's kind of left open-ended a
possibility for a sequel to emerge or at
the very least just kind of letting us
as the as the as the reader sort of
answer that question on our own kind of
descent into debates and different
things like that but that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the rod for if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later purse
[Music]